what we have here is the hudson valley
fisheries cold smoked steelhead trout
the sight of fish on a plane might be
worrying for some especially on a flight
that's going to last 19 hours just
layering this up nicely but not for
anthony mcneil i'm okay with it because
the product's super fresh it's super
tasty a chef with a background in
hospitality mcneal is now the food and
beverage director for singapore airlines
where he oversees the creation of the
280 unique dishes the airline offers
each month so that's our first class
salad but how does this smoke trout
salad get to this tray table exactly
mcneil is here to explain the logistics
behind flying this fish and how he uses
it to create a recipe made for some of
the world's longest flights
[Music]
singapore airlines operates four ultra
long-haul routes including two 19-hour
trips from jfk or newark to singapore
getting food prepared for these long
journeys is no small feat
from newark to singapore
we feature around 450 460 different meal
combinations from the meals which are
supplied on board so
whether it be the starter the three four
choices that you have for them for the
main course option desserts dinner
cheese so this is simply alliance first
class caviar service sourcing the
ingredients for these options is a
balance of both timing and taste
this salad tells that story
first timing
to see why mcneal calls this steelhead
trout fresh it's best to look at a map
this is john f kennedy airport this is
newark both have daily singapore
airlines flights that carry trout raised
here at hudson valley fisheries the fish
farm is located about 130 miles from
each airport
some catering partners or suppliers may
fly the steelhead trout from norway or
from chile so you're talking three and a
half thousand miles to five thousand
miles from these points of destination
into the country
mcneill estimates that journey could add
days to the fish's total transit time
whereas the trout from the hudson valley
doesn't have to fly to fly
and again very simply we're just going
to layer that into the salad the trout
used in this dish which mcneil is
assembling in a test kitchen goes from
tank to plane in under a week it's first
harvested at the farm and sent to a
smokehouse nearby after that it's sliced
and packaged which is when the clock for
singapore airlines really begins it's
sent off to our catering partners in jfk
and newark so within receipt of the
goods into the catering facility
generally you would see that flying on
board the aircraft within 24 36 hours of
that product arriving
from hudson valley fisheries topping
this off with a spicy watercress the
greens used in this salad are on the
plate in even less time around 24 hours
from when they're harvested that's
because they come from aerofarms an
indoor vertical farm in newark less than
five miles from the airport we're really
maximizing the freshness and the
closeness of the supply to the finished
plate i'm just going to finish that off
around
and over the salad but getting the
ingredients to the plane is only part of
the process
next is taste
we're just going to take the trout and
we're just going to pull it and so that
it flakes creating a travel ready recipe
is different from building a restaurant
ready meal because it's being served in
a pressurized cabin which changes how
passengers taste and feel when they eat
take the smoked steelhead for example
singapore airlines worked with hudson
valley fisheries to get the flavor right
for flight when we initially reviewed
the steelhead trout the feedback that we
gave the team was that it was slightly
too salty for our needs salt is
something airlines tend to load up on to
give food more flavor because travelers
taste buds dull in the arid dry plain
but too much salt can also lead to
dehydration making for an uncomfortable
trip so the flavor comes from elsewhere
this is the dressing so this is a tomato
vinaigrette with a ros hell nude spice
so the tomato is giving us some umami
flavor and then the razor and it will
give us a little bit of heat of course
mcneil isn't the one assembling
travelers meals once the recipes are set
they're given to airport catering
companies to prepare they're detailed
line by line each ingredient is clearly
identified with a weight requirement we
have a photograph depending on the cabin
class that you're flying for the
caterers to work to in terms of you know
where to put what ingredients and
sources where meals can be dished six to
eight hours ahead of the flight after
which they are held in chilling fridges
before being put on carts and lifted
onto the plane from there the crew is
given plating instructions this is on a
first class plate the order of the
ingredients radicchio beetroot leaves
trout radishes and their placement on
the plate are all predetermined here we
have the roasted beet fruits puree just
add that in at the end of the dish
properly plated the meal is ready to eat
and that chain that started in the
hudson valley is finally finished
somewhere at 30 000 feet
[Music]